yeah yes my arms are a different color
than my face
let's get that all the way I put fake
tan on fake use no I look like a little
girl that put her mom's makeup on for
the first time so I woke up this morning
and like we all do
to start our days on the best foot I
looked at social media cuz I just love
to be inundated with anxiety immediately
we all do it if lots of people do it
it's healthy I found this video he took
us with mustard on e and a flan beef and
sauerkraut and their cheese I saw that
this morning and I thought I need
content I like weird food combinations I
kind of clean my kitchen yesterday so
let's go get the ingredients and try
make mustard pizza and see if it's
actually delicious is this worth it this
long of an intro so I just got home but
I have to share this story before I
forget it cuz it was just a real quick
slice of life that was so stupid I was
at a four-way stop and when you're at a
four-way stop my understanding of the
rules of the road is you yield to the
person that gets there first I got there
first certainly after me a man in I'm
not car person so if you don't drive
like a Tesla or a mail truck I assume
that you Drive a 96 Corolla let's say
was in a 96 Corolla he got there after
me but he decided he got there first
and he just sped through his stuff side
and made direct eye contact with me
while wearing a fedora and for the first
time I felt like I could read lips so
perfectly because behind his closed
window of his 96 Corolla with this giant
plaid for he said yeah that's right
[ __ ] as he rolled through this four-way
stop it was the slowest worry stop of
all time it was the dumbest moment of
all time I want to say I applaud him but
I think he applauds himself enough and
you know he gave himself a boner because
he just felt like a badass let's go make
a pizza with sauerkraut and pastrami so
we got sauerkraut variety of shredded
Jesus and I
could not find corned beef at the
grocery store that I went to and I did
not want to venture to other grocery
stores so i google-searched the best
substitute for corn beef and most of the
answers were some form of roast beef or
pastrami so I got roast beef and
pastrami ingredients to try to make my
own pizza dough and also pre-made pizza
dough so I think I want to do is try to
make my own pizza dough this is our plan
B I've mentioned Plan B and two of two
videos this week I sponsors I looked up
how to make pizza dough from scratch and
basically you make it need to let it sit
for two hours so we're gonna do that
part first sound a quick basic pizza
dough recipe that's is exactly what it's
called on Martha Stewart comm I'm going
to have all of the ingredient just
because I don't know if I want that much
of a sauerkraut corned beef pizza you're
gonna use one and a half cups warm water
which means I'm gonna use 3/4 cup of
warm water and two envelopes
of active dry yeast it says this is 16
envelope so I need one envelope so I
need 1/16 of this we got our 3/4 cup our
1/16 of this which I don't know that
seemed good
now it says let it stand for 5 minutes
or until it gets like foaming I also
usually get foamy at the mouth after I
stand for more than 5 minutes so we army
okay you just follow me look look how
foamy that is now we need to whisk sugar
oil and salt into our yeast mixture and
then add flour and stir until a sticky
dough forms okay we need an oil Bowl
oiling the bowl this is so dry making
mustard pizza I mean like what's going
to be that good about it okay so we put
this and then we coat it in oil that's
where we're at I will see you in one
hour time to look at our pizza dough I
let it sit on the counter for like 30
minutes and then
it's a minimal like researcher oh my god
I was puked my mouth Oh foreshadowing I
did some research online and I saw that
you need to put in the refrigerator so I
put it in the refrigerator for the last
30 minutes let's see how it looks
whoa no sighs shaming just sighs aiming
Wow we did this wrong this is like
cookie dough this isn't what pizza
should look like everyone is different
in every size is okay and every texture
is okay never religion is okay
everything is okay like I said I did
some minimal research because the video
that I looked at one turns out it's from
New Jersey why am I surprised
this Jersey girl spotted another Jersey
garbage food video that people get are I
got garbage star this is such bad pizza
dough I did a very minimal research so
I'm gonna make this pizza however the
pillow it's supposed to be like
deep-dish I'm taking the deepest largest
hand I have olive oil spray we need to
roll out our dough this is cooking I'm
mad that grocery store Jo isn't the
bachelor uh we have a pizza crust I mean
it should be thinner probably but at
this point I don't give a single Wow a
variety of different mustard I thought I
only had one what a weird thing to feel
joyous about
there we go whoa she's a beaut now we go
on to the meat basically this whole meal
is just giving us that desperate salty
I'm drunk flavor you now in that video
they put sauerkraut and she's I assume
we don't want super wet sauerkraut yeah
I strained it a bunch and I felt weird
about it so now we're putting it on top
this is just an open-faced pastrami
sandwich okay so now I put cheese on I
got a mix of mozzarella and sharp white
cheddar pie oh yeah preemptively angry
and butt holes like that girl friend
that's like why did you go out I told
you not to go out and then you go out
and then you come back
drunk and she's like what are you doing
you put this in the oven I have it
preheated to 425 degrees 10 to 15
minutes who knows you're not here for
recipes good luck gross thing and that's
how people wish me well that so my 10
minutes is up but I think the pizza
needs a little more time one my stove is
a very dirty but two I think the pizza
could stand to be in there for a couple
more minutes unflattering angle says
let's do it I think our pizza might be
done whoa look at this look she came to
party this recipe says let it sit for at
least 10 minutes before you cut into it
and eat okay our pizza what a look I've
been resting for about 10 minutes time
to cut into it and see what kind of slop
trough we've made this time remember
this is mustard pizza you're not need to
remember you made it this far we're
gonna take this sweet corner Oh
time to eat Oh the crab very undone
underneath that's like most content
creators underneath it all we're a
little undone Cheers
okay it's honestly not that bad just the
crust is underdone all the ingredients
that I didn't have to cook sour crab
meat says cheese it and the mustard it's
all worked well together the one thing
that I tried to
ruins the rest of them if my maths adds
up maybe I should just stop cooking this
is an open-faced pastrami sandwich and
I'm so bummed that my pizza crust is
that shouldn't be bummed my expectations
were low and I met them wowie well
there's a whole trough of food that I
don't want to eat and I can't feed it to
my dog cheers to another cooking video
here on the grace Helbig youtube channel
if you like these kind of videos cuz I
like making them you want a thumbs up
and let me know in the comments down
below what you think as you cook the
next time and do not forget to subscribe
that's that Bella notification so you
know when I upload because I'm trying to
get back in this game imagine if this
was slime I'm lactose intolerant I did
this for you I don't know it looks so
good on the outside and it's soft and
flavorless on the inside Oh